et c'est avec anthony st léger qu'on
voit ça tout de suite bonsoir anthony
bon sens marion bonsoir sur les réseaux
sociaux des internautes profitent de la
crise économique et politique que
traverse le sri lanka pour diffuser des
infos qu effectivement le pays toujours
sous état d'urgence après plusieurs
semaines de manifestations violentes
contestations engendré on le rappelle
par une crise économique sans précédent
une information et une inflation record
regarder cette cet indice des prix qui a
plus que doublé entre décembre 2021 et
le mois d'avril des coupures
d'électricité des pénuries la décence
quotidienne qui toutefois inspire un
certain d'être dessinateur des pénuries
qui entraîne tout de même à des filles
datant de plus de dix heures 1 selon les
endroits et selon les témoignages
recueillis par nos équipes avec ce
changement de premier ministre censé
apaiser à la colère sans c'est parce que
ce n'est pas forcément le cas en tout
cas le terreau est fertile pour que ce
type de vidéos regardées rencontre un
certain succès sur les réseaux sociaux
elle est apparue sur twitter notamment
elle montre des hommes dénudés en partie
en tout cas exposé devant une foule qui
les prend en photo alors que dit la
légende regarder à la sûr que ce son adn
ministre sri lankais
c'est écrit ici elle précise même que le
pakistan a interdit toute information
venue du sri lanka pour éviter un effet
boule de neige alors une recherche
d'image l'inversé va nous ramener à à
plusieurs articles celui ci par exemple
ce tweet également ou encore cet autre
et tous nous explique que ces hommes
sont des détenus de la prison de
ouattara cas à colombo la capitale c'est
le point rouge que l'on voit ici
ils ont été filmés en marge d'une
manifestation le 9 mai à colombo contre
le gouvernement et ces manifestants sont
suspectés d'avoir été enrôlés par des
politiciens pour justement s'en prendre
à des manifestants dans cette
manifestation dans ce rassemblement du 9
mai mais ça c'est une version que le
département des prisons du sri lanka ni
dans un communiqué c'est ce qu'on
apprend via le site de la bbc en
cingalais l'une des langues du la
principale langue même du du sri lanka
l'autorité précise en fait que les bus
dans lesquels se trouvaient ces détenus
pour être transférés ont en fait été
attaqués par les manifestants
ils ont donc été agressés parce que
suspecté d'être favorables au
gouvernement alors deux versions qui
s'opposent mais en aucun cas il ne
s'agit deux ministres dénudé par et
humiliés par des manifestants une autre
vidéo évoque le passage à tabac du
ministre de l'information a
effectivement dans cette deuxième vidéo
que l'on voit ici on voit sept hommes en
sous-vêtement visiblement sonnés les
légendes affirme qu'il s'agit donc du
ministre de l'information tabassé par
des manifestants là encore c'est une
recherche de la vidéo qui va nous donner
à des informations via cet outil une
vidéo ea verify on retrouve cet extrait
dans une vidéo plus large que voici
regardez on reconnaît l'homme au centre
c'est lui donc la chemise rouge avec la
chemise rouge exactement alors ça ça
vient du compte twitter du journal sri
lankais daily mirror et cet homme n'est
pas et n'a jamais été ministre de
l'information il s'agit en fait du
président du syndicat des conseillers
municipaux et des employés de colombo il
avait organisé c'est ce qu'on voit au
début de la vidéo à un rassemblement en
faveur de l'ancien premier ministre le
frère du président qui a démissionné
c'était d'ailleurs avant qu'il
démissionne c'est ce qui lui a valu
d'être attaqué et d'être déshabiller par
des manifestants dont opposants au
pouvoir quant au vrai ministre de
l'information c'est lui vous voyez
aucune ressemblance physique nakagawa
alors lui n'a pas été personnellement
physiquement attaqués mais en tout cas
ça sa maison a été vandalisé le 12 mai
toujours marche de ces rassemblements
signe que même si ces vidéos ne montrent
pas ce qu'elles prétendent montrer les
attaques contre les politiciens ou des
biens qu'on leur appartenance ont bel et
bien réel avec cette contestation est
effectivement là c'est que des cas de
violence que vous nous montrez et il y
en a encore plus à reporter a
effectivement il y à la mort par exemple
d'amara kirti attoukora la députée du
parti au pouvoir qui a été lynché par
une foule de manifestants le 9 mai son
garde du corps avait auparavant tué par
balles un manifestant se souvient que
les les autorités avaient donné l'ordre
de tirer à vue sur les émeutiers à 6
nécessaire cette contestation et s'est
illustré aussi par du vandalisme on voit
ici cette voiture censée appartenir à
des membres du gouvernement jeter dans
une rivière de colombo ont dès le 11 le
11 mai puis il ya le domicile de
l'ancien premier ministre celui dont qui
a démissionné à mahinda rajapaksa qui a
été incendiée on voit ces images ici du
9 mai remercie beaucoup à anthony rester
avec nous un nouveau point sur
l'actualité dans quelques instants
[Musique]